I saw this interview from Kobe that I
just like loved and they said so most
athletes are either really afraid of
losing or they really want to win and he
says I don't think I'm either he just
wanted to do the absolute best he
possibly could divorce of outcome a lot
of people will say something like yeah I
just I just want to try really hard but
then there's like the second part of the
sentence where they're like so that I
can win so that I can whatever which
means that that's still not the goal
it's just the vehicle when I look back
on my life the things that I enjoyed the
most have been the pursuit not the goal
all my happiest times are like when I
was even in the struggle sleeping at the
gym like when you have a Worthy foe that
challenges you to the enth of your
ability and forces you to get better
that flow is where I feel most
[Music]
alive down